m
depuis le 8 décembre 2015 jusqu'au 27
mars 2016 le musée léon dierx propose
une exposition intitulée bernicat du 19e
siècle au début du 20e siècle les gorges
du bernica comptent parmi les sites les
plus célèbres de la réunion cette
profonde entaille dans les montagnes
dominant la ville de saint paul est
évoquée par george sand dans son roman
indiana et fait l'objet d'un poème écrit
par charles marie lecomte des grills le
bernica qui est une nouvelle exposition
qui est présenté dans le cabinet des
estampes et des arts graphiques du musée
long des axes et c'était un principe de
l'exposition que le musée va développer
dans les prochains mois les prochaines
années qui consiste en fait à partir
d'un tableau de paysages du musée landa
d'un site célèbre de la réunion est de
montrer à quel point ce site célèbre en
fête a été peint lithographier
photographiée pendant tout le dîner en
scène par de multiples artistes quant
aux multiples personnes qui se sont
intéressés à ce site est le premier opus
le premier volet de cette série
d'expositions commence avec bernicat et
avec la toile
d2f le roi qui a été peinte en 1884 que
le musée a acheté à peu près une
vingtaine d'années et qui est une toile
qui repose en fait les gorges du bernica
dans une vision un peu romantique
durant plus d'un siècle le bernica
témoigne de la splendeur de la nature
réunionnaise attirant de nombreux
peintres et photographes qui font de ce
cadre naturel abrupte et grandiose un
thème artistique dès 1804 en fait le
naturaliste jean baptiste maurice
vincent se rend sur le site et publient
dans le récit de voyage qui va en fait
faire à son retour en france il va faire
un album avec d'élite et gravures et
dans les rares lueurs il ya la
représentation du bernica et donc c'est
là ce document est une toute petite
gravure sur cuivre qui est un original a
été
et c'est la première vue des gorges de
guernica
on a ici trois lithographies 1847 1860
et 1880 donc à plusieurs paires
différentes où on voit que le site du
bernica a beaucoup intéressé roussin et
là ce qui est intéressant c'est que des
recherches qu'on a menées dans le cadre
de cette exposition nous ont permis
d'être d'entrer en contact avec un
collectionneur privé dans la réunion qui
nous a prêté une photographie puisque à
partir du moment où la photographie se
met en place à la réunion dans les
années 1860 1870 le bernica tout
naturellement devient un sujet
photographique un paysage que l'on va
aller photographier que l'on va
mémoriser que l'on pas rendre éternel à
travers le support photographique et là
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
fait dialoguer ici pratiquement sur le
moigne même point de vue le même angle
une vue il de graviers par ou saint lô
la réalité ne peut interpréter par
artiste et une photographie qui elle
donne vraiment un et à la réalité mais
dans la composition appelle beaucoup en
fait un document
dessiner une toute petite aquarelle d'un
peintre de marine qui s'appelle maurice
ménardeau et ces documents est
intéressant parce que c'est sa première
idée pour une immense toile qui fait
appliquer trois mètres de long sur 2
mètres de haut qui se trouve aujourd'hui
conservée dans la salle des mariages de
l'hôtel de ville de saint denis ou pour
site qui la toile s'appelle les âges de
la vie et où situe-t-il les âges de la
vie cette composition un peu allégorique
devant les gorges du médical donc c'est
pour montrer à quel point jusqu aux
années 30 le manica reste dans la
mémoire collective et reste un lieu
incontournable de l'art et la
littérature la poésie la peinture et la
photographie témoigne de l'importance du
bernica dans l'histoire des paysages
réunionnais emblématique ce symbole a
été oubliée aujourd'hui des circuits
touristiques et des livres de souvenirs
sur la réunion 6 leconte de lisle y
trouver refuge pour oublier le monde le
bernica aujourd'hui a été oubliée du
monde